- So, a Florida woman was arrested
for calling 911 more than 12,000 times.
I mean, I guess the only thing worse
than calling the police
and them not helping you
is calling the police over 12,000 times
and them not helping you.
This particular woman
called over 500 times
in just one 24-hour period.
Look, I get it.
You're not a fan of the police. Fair.
But 12,000 calls is probably excessive.
Police officials said
that her calls accounted
for 12% of incoming traffic
at that particular police department.
The criminal complaint against this woman
includes a bunch of First
Amendment protected activity.
It says she continuously
calls, harasses, belittles,
swears at, argues with,
and demands officers come arrest her.
Then she refuses to answer the door,
has in the past given
officers the middle finger
and screams at them through the windows.
And while flipping off
the police is not a crime,
making thousands of false 911 calls is.
But at least here we have a happy outcome
because after 12,000 calls,
she was arrested again,
just as she requested.